what's up cowabunga dudes
we are here we are big mood we are in
the 90s today if you're watching this on
video if you're watching on audio you
want to come back
watch the video who we got today we got
nikki i don't know
we got gina we got tim we got jess
and today we are talking about
instagram versus reality because i think
it's a huge thing that a lot of people
are going through right now
where social media has ramped up a lot
in quarantine
and as you're scrolling through your
feeds um you're starting to feel
like maybe a little inadequate maybe
behind because you're watching
everybody's highlight reel basically of
their life and
you are seeing all the things that you
were lacking and you're wondering
am i a loser am i a [ __ ] ass
loser and maybe you want a story short
in your life but
the answer is yes yeah i mean basically
because their instagrams are a reality
it's true
do we before we start do we want to
address the reality of what's happening
visually right now because it's a little
weird that we don't address
that we are ninety so we said we were in
the 90s i don't understand what's what's
wrong
yessica 1992.
since this stream like this uh this
recording is actually our laggiest
because yeah this is really like
throttling or some [ __ ]
so this is so 90s appropriate
yeah we need to like it together switch
to a different platform besides zoom
because they're throttling our [ __ ] so
[ __ ] you zoom
well maybe la will release the lockdown
and we'll actually go back to our studio
soon
yeah that would be dip i have been
loving the themes
so much by the way it's like going to a
halloween party every week yeah
yeah i missed it so everyone has their
own
like 90s look right now jess would you
like to describe yours
mine is a grunge vegas
heroine hooker how about you nikki
um so mine's like more of i feel like
i'm a sitcom
character best friend oh like i'm not
the main character
the neighbor the neighbor miranda
from uh yes thing i forgot her name
the name you're like um yeah or kimberly
from full house lizzie mccoy
yes yeah yeah your best friend that
climbs through the windows and the
parents are like oh my god
go home nikki can i borrow your
headphones
my walkman's broke that bucket hat
like i can't believe you even own that
that thing's something dude
well these are back in style first of
all so you shut your mouth um
secondly i bought this because my uh
my coordinator of big mood photo shoots
gina darling uh said there was a 90s
theme
and she wanted specifically baby blue
and baby pink and so i bought
baby blue bucket hats but then
quarantine happened so we were not
allowed to do
you were not able to do the photo shoot
but i still have to use it today
yeah how about you tiff well what are
you doing
what's your name i got my rasa
inspiration
that's why i got my vida loca
yeah right here you see and then i'm
wearing like
my los angeles
guess what i actually found my
tiffany gold chola little like mexican
bracelet
that i've had since um i was a child i
don't know but
it's so old like it needs cleaning but i
found it
and i'm wearing some overalls and then
like oh shout out to stacey diaz this is
from her
her jewelry line it's really cool i like
that
i know like it matches perfect and yeah
yeah that's what i got going on
you guys have no idea like ever since i
met tiff i've been waiting to see her in
this book
like this you have a chola fetish
yeah like it's just me it's her name is
lupita today
i mean that was going to be my birth
given name lupita yeah
i've talked really before it was going
to be
because my mom's just really quick my
mom's due date was december i think 15.
and that was that's
which is like the virgin mary's birthday
or something and
she said like her and my dad had agreed
that if i was born on that day
my name would be guadalupe but luckily i
was two
on weeks 29th and my dad won
because he loves tiffany and company and
like he really liked the jewelry and all
that so
i got tiffany i'm really glad you are
named after the jewelry
mm-hmm oh cute i am
[Laughter]
do you know what you got going on you
got lisa frank background what's up
i don't what this is like this is like
high school
yeah right this is no high school no
it's another lisa
is like elementary school elementary
yeah
like elementary school my makeup i
looked up like old gwen stefani makeup
mm-hmm that's still elegant yeah yeah
get closer to the camera i want to see
your eyebrows
oh my eyebrows are disgusting you
covered it
damn that looks good though it looks
amazing
you did blue eyeshadow too right yeah
and
[ __ ] i should have thought of that i
didn't even think about the makeup part
real good
i just thought about it this is the
first time i hand drew like my
winged liner and like spiders i'm like i
don't know what i'm doing but because
remember i
i know nikki knows but i had like these
eyeliner stamps like to make the wings
but i threw them out when i moved but
anyway um
i like so i had to erase my eyebrows my
real eyebrows
so i have like glue stick on my eyebrows
right now like seven layers of concealer
oh my gosh
you could have just left your eyebrows
on and then draw on another line
just really dark james
parties and then um brown lipstick
because everyone had brown lipstick
yeah brown eyeliner but it like blended
in
i was gonna go the frosted pink look but
i couldn't find any frost
and um and then like i had this already
and then like
i think people wore these tops a lot
back then like yeah
yeah yeah they did yeah and of course i
have a slew of backgrounds that i will
be rotating through today
one thing that i wanted to do that i
didn't get to do was uh take my hair you
remember those like twisty cornrows like
oh yeah
[Applause]
yeah you didn't actually know how to do
cornrows like but they still wanted a
copy
but i was like in this day and age it's
not appropriate for me to do anything
cornrow
oh no really i wouldn't even label it as
cornrows like i mean
i guess it technically is but because
like i used to like spend all day in
middle school like in my room
locked up in my room and be like oh let
me just play with my hair and like i
just like learn how to do like the
twisty thingy yeah and i don't
have like the whole thing like this or
sometimes i'll just do one side and i
felt like a badass because i'm like
like i have like a shade like you shaved
your head yeah yeah
so you guys remember when girls would
like literally like glue
down their front bangs oh i did that i
did that and i put a little clip on the
side yeah
i remember that dude so for some i was
so obsessed with having a straight line
like it had to be the straightest hook
and line ever and two clips
mine was a side one and then it was
gelled it was gelled with like this gold
gel because my parents wouldn't let me
dye my hair but so i
found like the most glitteriest gold gel
and i would put it with the two like i
do like clips here i remember the color
gel i used to have like blue and like
you put it in your hair but it was like
hard so you just have like crunchy blue
yeah
like pieces of your hair and you'll
remember
all the body glitter i used to put
i didn't even like i i saw your eyes
like pop so much but i didn't know it
was glitter that looks like yeah
i like it i feel like
oh my god this is a perfect time perfect
[ __ ] sideways current britney spears
instagram is a hot
[ __ ] mess if you have not seen
britney spears current instagram
you have to go see it you have to just
go all the way down like i
spend hours yeah yeah for all the times
you spent looking at magazines of
britney spears and then i need to be
like oh my god she's perfect i want her
life yeah her instagram will make you go
oh britney you're a real person
dude growing up
like i was obsessed with justin
timberlake like
in sync i was so obsessed so i i had
like this deep rooted wait just turned
for
okay i thought it was bigger for a
second oh my god no timberlake i had
this deep rooted hatred for brittany
because they were together
[ __ ] stole my man i was literally 11
years old 11
thinking this awesome so they've now
seen her like my inner 11 year old is
like hey
she's like as [ __ ] now dude like i said
her instagram and i was like oh
you need a nap sweetheart like you need
she needs a lot more than that
i just want to brush her hair and give
her a hug and give her all she
needs to get out of the sun like who's
letting her in the sun
she has white skin and it is falling
apart
but do you know what i love about her
instagram is like she's just living her
life and she
looks very happy and i'm like you know
what she's meditating
well she's living her life
she has a cute boyfriend she has a
really hot boyfriend
yeah i think he's like an old is he an
olympian or he's like some sort of
athlete
right i don't know i think he was some
sort of athlete
dude there's a picture of him like at
dinner with her and he
like i guess she had covered the red eye
with black like literally black
dog yeah black dots
she was doing like microsoft paints
photoshop
holy crap or britney i know
my 11 year old is having a blast but
currently 30 year olds
i feel bad for her but she's literally
that's why feel instagram
like you had to have a crush on eminem
tip you [ __ ] up because all he did was
write hate songs about his wife and i'm
like yeah
i did yeah i didn't really like um pop
in the 90s
he said something about christina
aguilera too at one point and i was like
oh yeah we'll leave her out of this poor
christian it was because
she was talking about him on a on a mtv
special
and like he didn't like that she was
talking about him and his ex-wife
on um on a tv special and then she was
like he's cute though
he and that's what oh i see that's funny
in his song um but my instagram is
totally 90s because i feel like
i just i feel like instagram right thank
you
does steve photos or are you tripoding
that both
like i switch off sometimes he i mean i
don't want to bother him but
um yeah and then other times i'll have
it i'll be like i need that perfect shot
do it
the effort is there and i appreciate it
i haven't i only upload like every two
weeks now
yeah i feel like i've ramped it up since
quarantine because
there's nothing else to do and also it
started because i had just bought a
bunch of new clothes
online and then i didn't have anywhere
to wear them and i was like but
i need these can't go to waste i cannot
have these
in vain so i just uh yeah i just started
doing like little mini photo shoots and
i'm more into photo editing
than i am into taking photos actually
taking photos part
is really difficult for me hey i'm like
so awkward and i'm
trying to look trying to feel like i'm
casual but
i really really love editing photos i
feel
great so thank you can you
like take over my body and do that page
too i feel like
right now you have the best instagram
out of all of us sorry ladies yeah yes
your instagram's killing it nikki thanks
guys i didn't feel that way before
quarantine
i looked at my instagram like an art
project though not like a
not like a real documentation of my life
i'll just take pictures like one day of
the week when i
when i want to dress up and put makeup
on the rest of the week is
no makeup which is a really good
highlight of instagram vs reality
because
my reality is mostly in sweatpants all
day long
pajamas all day long no makeup hair a
mess
i don't know when the last time i
showered blah blah blah
yeah but for me every time i wash my
hair is an event
i'm like hold on yes wash my hair today
me too
all right oh my
yeah the god is like washing your hair
or going to target we're basically trash
as of late you guys
like my my [ __ ] my fancy vacation
that i took this summer it was my
two-hour trip to target so two hours
jesus what were you doing in there
waiting you can't spend less than two
hours girl
and you can't spend less than two
hundred dollars because target takes
your money
it's pretty good you didn't know you
needed five throw pillows well now you
do
[ __ ] it calls me a [ __ ] and i'm like
oh my god i'm so threatened
you like to do this i do like it
i'm turned on i'm scared
i noticed that there's like so many
people like oh my gosh i want to be like
this girl or that girl or this girl
she's so skinny she's my blood and i'm
just like
i hope you guys realize that 99.99999999
of all them are photoshopped
like a lot of people like even the
fitness gurus they photoshop their
photos a lot of them photoshop and
photos too
you know yeah the angles are very like
you know deceiving yeah basically yeah
yeah
yeah there are some instagram accounts
that show the actual photoshop that
celebrities do to their photos like they
they show like candid photos that we're
talking about afterwards yeah
yeah it's really good it's pretty nice
and like we all have pores it's
you know they all have like they
photoshop out their pores and stuff and
then
i think a lot of i think now people kind
of forgot what people really look like
yeah it's like dysmorphia 100
mm-hmm so like now when they see a photo
without like without the skin smooth
that they're like oh my god what the
[ __ ] it's like dude that's
normal like yeah they're like oh if
she's ugly it's like
no she's real yeah but a true way to get
really healthy glowing skin and have a
lean
fit body is to eat properly
yes get your vitamins get it through
your food and
the way that i do that and this is oh my
gosh i'm on a
subscription to daily harvest now
because they had gifted us our first
batch
to try out because they were sponsoring
the show but i can't stop ordering
because i love it so much
i'm addicted to daily harvests my
favorite or the
freaking well lately because the
weather's changed to warm it's been the
ginger and green smoothies because it
has a little kick
where like i feel like my energy gets
boosted and the greens in it get covered
by the ginger
and this a little bit of the sweetness
and so i don't feel like i'm eating
vegetables but i get all the nutrients
of the vegetables it's been like the
number one thing that's combated
like anxiety for me whenever i'm feeling
anxiety i
like it's like a like a turbo shot of
vegetables but
um that's just my personal experience
with the with the fresh fruit vegetable
type smoothies i really liked their
oatmeal bowls before when the weather
was colder
but daily harvest delivers clean food
right to your door so all the food is
built on fruits and vegetables there's
no preservatives there's no added sugar
there's no artificial ingredients
it takes just a few minutes to prepare
and i never question if what i'm eating
is healthy because
it's it all is thanks to the i like how
they list the ingredients too
it's really really simple in each cup
too it tells you exactly what's in it
yeah and then they have a little bingo
chart too with stickers so you could see
if you're getting
like enough fruits and vegetables every
day have you filled yours out yet
no but i took all the stickers and put
them in my bullet journal
yeah i was like i'm sure nicki's gonna
find a use for these
yeah cute they're so cute
but everything stays fresh in your
freezer until you're ready to enjoy it
you don't have to overthink any of your
meals for the week they have
delicious options for any time of day
there's smoothies soups harvest bowls
flatbreads they even have like pizzas
daily harvest works directly with the
farms and they freeze organic fruits and
vegetables at peak ripeness to lock in
nutrition and taste
and they're committed to minimizing
their environmental impact so uh
they're in the process of transitioning
to 100 compostable recyclable packaging
and are over 50 of the way there already
so go to dailyharvest.com and in a promo
code
big mood to get 25 off your first box
that's a lot it's promo code big mood
for 25 off your first box of daily
harvest dot com
daily harvest dailyharvest.com do it
yay yay
so instagram i've i feel like you
also because i was analyzing like why do
certain people's posts make me feel bad
and other people's don't and i think for
me personally
it's got to be like whatever i feel like
i'm lacking in life
right now when people are posting that
and seem to be having it in abundance
and it's coming easily to them
i just feel really bad so for some
people that's relationships and if they
see relationship photos they
feel it makes them feel bad for like
last year when i was
trying to lose weight and i was like
having a really tough time
all of those fitness gurus those like
healthy
health people that like it's so easy all
i do is this and i have a six pack
those are making me feel bad so which
ones are making me feel bad
recently travel ones no
i actually know what's traveling
yeah oh like from the past like memories
and stuff no for me
the ones that cuz like you're saying all
this nikki and i'm like yeah i think
most people
feel like that where they they'll feel
bad if they go
on social media so right now i was
questioning myself i'm like do i ever
feel that i don't think i do
but then i remembered when i do come
across like more recently when i come
across
instagram posts of people either
announcing that they're pregnant or
their pregnancy
belly or their baby uniform baby like
that [ __ ] like it's
it like makes me sad because i'm like
damn it like i wanna
i wanna do that again too you know like
i
i don't know like i guess it does make
me feel a little bit like
i'm missing out kind of is it is it i
mean because you said like you didn't
really want to right now
because of everything going on but is it
just more like that's the reason like
just getting
getting rid of the idea of the
quarantine like you just still wanted a
baby this year
so it's like yes yeah so because of the
quarantine is why
like i made like the logical decision to
not continue to like
try like we both made yeah we made that
decision together but like the emotional
side of things where i'm like
i i was just like you know like for so
many years i always felt like i wasn't
ready for a second kid
especially being a teen mom like there's
just no way like i
i can't i couldn't even wrap my head
around like wanting another kid
especially after
everything so now like going into this
year
where we're both like [ __ ] yeah we're
ready let's do this let's make this
happen
let's expand our family we got our house
now and
like to not like continue that like
not work towards that goal like i don't
know seeing it on instagram it kind of
does bum me out a bit because i'm like
damn it but
i could see that for sure what about you
jess are there any pictures that
like specific types of posts that yeah i
think the ones
just like where um i mean i don't really
feel
bad because like i i kind of don't like
i'm choosing to not really participate
in
instagram and like i know a lot of work
goes into like actually having a good
instagram and like constantly having new
pictures and really cute [ __ ] but just
like
the ones i guess even it doesn't make me
feel bad but i feel
envious of i guess like feeds like yours
nikki where like you
like you have just a ton of like really
cute pictures like
and i'm just like oh it's so much work
so like i don't feel bad about myself
when i see it but i'm just like damn i
wish i
like could hurry up and get through all
of that work and then have the end
result of like having a ton of these
like really cute pictures you know what
i mean
um there's not anything like like
relationships don't really make me feel
bad right now
um babies definitely don't make me feel
bad
um skinny i mean i i'm i'm one of those
people right now that's doing the losing
weight thing so i guess
that doesn't make me feel bad um i don't
know so yeah i guess maybe it's just
like having like an instagram that's
like very curated and like looks really
good and like you're cute in every
picture i'm like ugh
i can i know i can do it it's so much
work but it just kind of makes me feel
like yeah
i completely relate to that jess too
because like i
i even talked about this in jk where i
feel like
i don't know what it is but over the
years like this has
been growing for me where i'm getting
like further and further away like
growing distant from my social media
pages because in the beginning it was
something that was so
pure and so like genuine and so like i
was so excited for it
and like to share and like i was i don't
know like it was just so
something else and then slowly over the
years like you know we get
it like it's no longer fun i mean it is
fun but like
it's not pure fun now it's like hard
work so every time i do
open up the social media apps no matter
what it is
mainly instagram i end up feeling guilty
that i'm not
doing my job because now it's my job
like to actually post and when i'm not
doing it and
i open it i feel like i'm not i don't
know
i feel like i'm doing something wrong
yeah the only way i
like get away from that feeling is like
i keep my stories kind of going but half
the time i'm just reposting other
people's content
like memes and [ __ ] or like i'll pop in
and or i'll show pictures of my dogs and
stuff i'm like i'm putting
something on there so i guess i like
that though i think i like stories more
than in food posts like honestly getting
just a look at everyone's life
yeah in like their you know true form
yeah i like that [ __ ]
my mommy is just like i i i'm envious of
well i mean people aren't traveling now
but they're old travel photos i've
always been like oh i wish i can do that
because like they're done
so well like this [ __ ] is in a bikini
lane and insanity pulls somewhere out in
[ __ ]
micronesia or something you know yeah
and then like i've always wanted to do
that but it is a lot of work
and like i am
color challenged because like
the way they edit their photos and they
color correct everything is so nice
if you were to show me a picture that
was completely orange i'd be like yeah
that's way too
cool like that's definitely white
like i am so bad at it you know yeah oh
like cool
temperature
[Applause]
like i'm just not i don't have that eye
so whenever i see other ones like [ __ ]
that's so [ __ ] cool
have you ever gotten tested for
colorblindness because like that's kind
of partly true some of it like
no because i'm perfect in everyone it
just sounds like she doesn't know the
terminology
or like it's just i don't know the the
right
like i don't know i just don't have an
eye for like you guys are
more artists than i am like nikki tiff
just like you guys can decorate like
tiff and jess are like i mean uh tiffany
care like they have colors in their
houses where i'm saying
i would never put that because i don't
know how you know but you're so
creative with your photo shoots i'm like
i don't even know how your brain thinks
that way because i don't
know concepts like that i
i come up with concepts and then i let
like stylist execute
you know what i mean like that's tight
that's the thing the team helps
yeah i can come up with concepts i can't
execute
you know what i mean yeah cause i get
overwhelmed
well that's why we make a good team i
can't wait for our next big mood photo
shoot because i can't come up with
concepts at all
uh and i can't photograph but
like the photo editing is my jm so like
you know casey was helping out with you
know taking pictures and stuff
before even steve came in took some
pictures i feel like we
could combined our forces combined we
could make some
good photos we can do it one of my
favorite pictures that we have is all of
us laying
on the ground do you remember that we
took that on the outside all of us
laying on the ground like kind of
looking up in a circle
super cute that one was really cute i
miss being together you guys
i know remember friendship
[Laughter]
do you sometimes watch movies right now
and like when people hug
each other or like shake hands you're
like oh no
oh no it slightly crosses my mind where
i'm like oh
that is that going to happen again or it
takes me out of the thing because i'm
like oh we can't touch people or
like have massive crowds right in a
restaurant anymore it just feels weird
i feel bad for all the touch love
language people because i'm like damn
how are you guys going to cope
just you guys might as well just [ __ ]
you wishes quarantine
together dude like just stay together
i need all of the physical touch people
i need to tell you someone to quarantine
with
yeah like all the physical touch people
just [ __ ] just put it all together
man
that's actually my second language so i
guess i'm halfway in there
i don't know at least you have someone
to touch you
true we can always touch ourselves jess
it's okay
yeah use your left hand then it feels
like a stranger
it just feels like somebody doesn't know
what they're doing i don't like that
with that [ __ ] hat which is perfect
i'm the neighbor that comes over gives
you advice bye thanks for the
screwdriver
yeah yeah you know what um you know one
of my pet peeves
on instagram are is
are okay english
[ __ ] besides terrible grammar um
i like the blatantly obvious fake
followers
yes like okay honestly
i think some celebrities like i think
their managers
buy them for them or something too
because i'll notice a lot of times like
like i'll follow like like a real
housewife of beverly hills or something
and i'm like her engagement is super
[ __ ] low like yeah did
the network lifetime or whatever you
know like uh what is it oxygen or bravo
i'm like
are they buying these fake followers too
because like it's super awkward for a
celebrity
to have that for sure i think um because
i used to think that too
a lot where i'm like what's happening
with all these
millions of follower accounts and then
you look at each post as like a thousand
likes or something i'm like that's
pretty bad that is a clear sign for sure
they have fake followers but the other
like fake follower phenomenon that i see
is like
there's a whole bunch of like spam
accounts that end up commenting on
everyone's
posts it's like they always leave the
most generic comments like
wow cool so sexy cool photo cool picture
or like a picture like and it's a
picture of a [ __ ] tree like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
yeah so so when i see comments like that
i used to judge people where i'm like oh
they bought their followers like oh my
god it's so obvious but then all of a
sudden all these [ __ ] comments came
to my page and i'm like
i've never purchased they're like
they're like where are they coming from
yeah oh my gosh or people like tagging
you in random [ __ ] like random like
indian uh like head shots i'll get
checked out
yeah seriously like people
it's not even indian like there's like
random just like americans too that just
tag me in their selfies and i'm just
like what am i
supposed to do with this like yeah dude
i'm like
untagging people's [ __ ] from i'm like
why are you tagging i don't get it
and they're not even following so yeah
how did you find me
to tag this or like people who tag me in
giveaways when the giveaway says tag
your friends yeah
and i'm just like i don't [ __ ] know
you like tag your friends
get real friends and tag them don't
bother me if they don't have friends
gina
that's then you have more to worry about
than a [ __ ] giveaway honestly i think
i wonder if the giveaway people look and
they're like oh this is like clearly an
influencer
it's not your friend sometimes you know
sometimes with our own pages too like if
like gina has a giveaway or something
then we're all getting tagged
when people do that sometimes i call
them back like i don't know you please
don't tag me
and then like like when i have time i'm
just like bored i'm like i don't know
you please don't tag me it says tag your
friends
and then some of them will get [ __ ]
pissed like [ __ ] you why would you even
care you have so many followers anyways
why do you [ __ ] care
and i'm like they got mad because
they're like i thought we were friends
gina
i used to block them all the time and
now i get too many so i'm like [ __ ] i
can't keep up with the blocking but
too popular jess no not at all i'm not
at all but like when i first
like first came on the scene and i had
like 10 000 you know i could
i could see each one i'd be like nope
[ __ ] you
yeah or keep a tight ship or like they
get they get they get angry for spamming
me
yeah getting called out for it it's like
what the [ __ ] are you doing dude
like you were supposed to look so then i
tagged so sometimes if they if they're
really rude i'll tag the person that
soon they would be like hey can you make
sure this person doesn't win
they probably freak out too because they
think that person is actually going to
see it even though they still already
have like way too many notifications
so ridiculous like they probably
pre-planned who they
were picking to win too oh yeah oh true
all those big big ones i'm like like
when they're like a trip to
come meet us and have dinner or
something you know like i'm like
instagram they call these things
instagram pods that i got invited to
where it's like pods like it's a group
message with all like big big
followers like people big accounts and
then um
what they do is everything they post a
new photo they send it to that
group chat and then everyone that group
chat supposed to like and leave a
comment
and so like they all like it's basically
like circle jerking each other into
group chat
yeah i haven't been doing that on
youtube for a while but really um
when it used to matter because it used
to show up in people's feeds when other
big youtubers would even instagram too
it used to show up but then they blocked
that
like it doesn't pop up you know it was
something interesting i
um i participated in or whatever
was i went to this event thing and i met
some girl there she was super sweet
really nice
um she ended up asking me for this thing
where i'm like i didn't know people did
this but she was like
hey is it cool if i shout you out on my
stories that like i met you
and like all this stuff like would you
be down to do it back because she
like i guess i can try followers like i
had more than her or whatever
um but i was like yeah dude like totally
like i don't mind but
apparently that's something that a lot
of people do when they're trying to grow
their
their page or i'm like oh that's pretty
smart like i didn't
think of that stuff i i understand that
too and it's really smart but then i'll
get
people like hey can we cross-post each
other i'll give you exposure to my
people and it's like 800 followers and
i'm just like
what you don't like how someone uses the
word exposure
i cringe i cringe so hard dude
like especially like it's if it's a cold
call like that
i would i would feel weird too but the
fact that i meant because it kind of
feels like that too like with this girl
like it was pretty much that
like yeah like hey let's exchange like
i'll you know i'll get eyeballs like
like my people to you whatever um if i
didn't meet her and she just
asked me like asked me to do that in the
dm i'd be like this is weird
sometimes i would do it if they're if
their engagement was real because it
just makes sense like it's cross
promotion
but like i said like you know your
audience man like you can't go from like
800 followers asking people like half a
million you know like
yeah i also only do that if like the
audience is matched because
i got asked to do that by um i don't
know what i knew in real life but their
their whole profile was like nude
like sexy sexy sexy high
sexy pictures like all of their
demographic was horny men
and they were like you're like i don't
want those guys in my place
i don't want that i'm trying to
translate she's like
she's like i need girl followers can i
have some of yours
yeah have you ever seen them like i'm
very well aware that everyone photoshops
their photos and it's cool whatever
minor tweaks hanging there but have you
seen like blatantly bad ones
like oh yes yeah like their waist is
small but the window in the background
was like yes
yes there's so many there's some
accounts like
instagram versus reality but what
they're called
um on my own page like early instagram
days because like i was
i was super super super self-conscious
of my dark circles
and i would like try to like blur them
out but
you know with the freaking pho like
photo editing
apps and like the early iphone it was
pretty bad it was pretty bad
but now i look back on those old
instagram posts and i'm like you could
clearly see i was like blurring out
though
remember how tight we thought it was
like when you could blur the background
and like have that fake depth of field
and now
yeah the vignette thing and then i look
back
i have some like friends from high
school that i follow that are still
doing that i'm like [ __ ]
all i see is nostril where's the rest of
your face
like getting her out of like 10 years
ago thing to do
they're still dressed like this
have you have you guys ever heard of a
thing they referred to it on instagram
as um
the hood filter the hood no like
it's like it's all like i remember i
knew this like this kind of like really
chola chick
and they always use the same exact
filter where they turn up the hdr like
crazy
what's that i wonder if i can share
something it makes everything like
really like
no i don't think you can but it makes
like everything like really like
definite like defined super contrast
oh wait like fitness people do that so
you could see like all the little tiny
uh all their muscles they would always
like turn up that
really high too but also you know who
does that as a joke or not a joke but
like celebness
yeah celebness turns up that structure
is super high so you could see all the
celebrity wrinkles and
by the way oh celebration i think we
were about to talk about steve
doing i was gonna say can we just oh the
fakest [ __ ] ever
on instagram what are you talking about
like ever like you can totally tell her
photos in photoshop
i don't like the fact that you can't see
her nose at all i know right and like
that stupid face she's always making to
try to make her cheekbones
look it's better she just has a like
really good
um skincare routine you guys should
check her out at
stevegreen comedy dot com no
yeah comedy.com the instagram doesn't
have.com on it
instagram.com steve green comedy oh wait
super real comedy.com
yeah the fakest [ __ ] i've ever seen
she really likes her face looks like her
face looks like a cloud
she's just trying to inspire people
everybody like she's not her fault she's
pretty
really small too because everything
around it is so blurred and there's just
like funny
things the eyes like the whites of the
eyes so much
yeah she's so conceited every time she
takes pictures something she's like
the half of photos just her face and
like whatever is that she wants to play
in the background like
i feel like you're just hating gina i
don't know maybe
you know what it's fine like it's
because i envy her like instagram
reality and stuff i wish my life was
hers
my favorite is that he does it in group
shots he doesn't
photoshop a person with a
fake friend fake friend yeah in a minute
huh
uh he's like because he's doing a new i
think he's doing a re-brand every like
six years
he will do a rebrand because sometimes i
tell him your bit's going too long it's
been like years already i feel like
still getting a little old
yeah so before that one he had a foot
fetish one all of his pictures on
instagram were all feet and he would
talk about like
he would have like a feet um on a couch
and he would be like
um i just got a new couch isn't it cool
and you could barely see the couch you
can just only see like this person's
foot
wow and it'd be a guy's feet girl's feet
all kinds of
beating shoes yeah and then you know
with his movies
yeah like when people would call him out
for having a foot fetish he'd be like i
don't know what you're talking about i
was i was taking a picture of the
furniture
see that's why you can't believe
everything on instagram like people
they'll either be doing bits because i
remember coming across his page for the
first time and i'm like
it's split second i was like what the
[ __ ] is this guy doing really
but then like it took me you know like a
second and i'm like oh my god this is
[ __ ] hilarious
look at the comments and people are like
um this is like
way too over yeah why are you doing this
so much like yeah
but then i'm like i like they could
easily be like playing into the troll
too and i'm obviously
thinking they believe it so like i'm
getting trolled by the trolls getting
trolled like um
it's like this whole world that just
can't get curated and it's kind of like
um
you remember the old saying from like
our time the 90s time where you'd be
like don't believe everything you see on
tv kind of thing
now it's like don't believe everything
you see on social media because
for sure not everything is like factual
or whatever for sure
like my instagram like i may look
perfect and my life is amazing and i'm
incredible but i have bad breath in the
morning guys
yeah right you also don't clean your
room all the time
green screen i would like to know what's
behind that green screen that's an
artistic
choice jess she's perfect it's actually
sorry it's okay today
i remember i was introduced to this girl
um who's like she had my friends
introduced me to her
they're like yeah she's like a huge
instagrammer she's a blah blah she's
amazing blah blah
and i like she looked kind of like oh
he does stop stop you know and then i
was like oh that's really sweet she's so
humble
and then i looked at her instagram and
she had like 800 000 followers
but she had like 500 likes and i was
like oh
that's why you're like oh my god please
stop
like i wouldn't be able to live with
myself if like
you don't want to meet me either that's
embarrassing it's very embarrassing
because
anyone who knows like would be like oh
god they're gonna look at my profile and
they're gonna know you know
unless like in the early days in the
early days it would trick companies
because i remember like girls getting
huge brand deals
because companies are dumb in the
beginning yeah
like know how to look for engagement
versus
um followers yeah not anymore but i
wonder like
can you like get ready can you yourself
purge like
you know 500 000 fake i feel like
there's got to be something that will
allow you to do that didn't instagram do
that like they purged all the different
followers
everyone's like some [ __ ] yeah i think
there's a huge celebrity
celebrity account that went down to over
like ten thousand people yeah justin
bieber lost like three million or
something
yeah but it's it's not their fault
though i mean they're really like we're
seeing these are it's almost like
virus accounts like they just yeah like
they're just
eating up all these uh you know the
internet by following everyone's like no
one's doing it on the internet
but i feel like um what kind of accounts
do you guys actually
like following because i feel like i
follow
i try to follow brands that are like
accounts that inspire me
and i think it's only when it goes
beyond the point of inspiration to
making me feel
bad that like that's when the bad
feelings happen like
it used to be people that were super
productive where i just felt really
behind like they'd be on their fifth
book or something and i'm like yeah
i don't know what i'm doing with my life
most of the people i follow on instagram
like a high high percentage of it is
people that i know in real life like or
people's like
people that i knows companies or
whatever it is like
that's like most of the people that i
follow um
but if it's not that then i think i i
have
more recently been gravitating towards a
lot of like interior design type of
yeah instagram pages or if it's not that
then it's like
visual asmr type of pages where it's
like the
the the power washer cleaning cleaning
thing yeah
or like um i followed like a couple
slime pages once like yeah in the
beginning when it was popular
yeah it's just so like
visually pleasing or like i love it or
like cake cake decorating videos yeah
i love cake decorating cookie decorating
i love that
yeah or cookie decorating i like
following a lot of food accounts
actually
it comes down to any i think i have like
one donut page
yeah i follow a lot of bullet journal
pages now like the
calligraphy just watching it's kind of
the same calligraphy people doing
calligraphy yeah yeah
i don't have anything like coloring
inside the lines like i don't know why i
just it works yeah
dude i love so like lots of travel ones
but i also love like
pages that post just like dumb [ __ ] like
yeah you know whatever
memes and stuff me mine's mostly memes
i think there's there's a page called
drunk people doing things that's
hilarious
um clothes and a lot of the meme
accounts i follow is because of jess
actually yeah
i mean like 30 members
dude every time you post
people respond they're like oh it's
private i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] follow it
you guys yeah i had to follow because of
youtube yeah
oh and as of lately there's been a lot
of animal crossing idea
pages hell no no you really don't even
start with the animal crossing
i do that on twitter we do a whole
freaking i want to get out of it
like with animal crossing because i were
we meet in animal crossings
i want to build like a set what the hell
everything in my upstairs room and
animal crossing
what happened like oh cheers to that
yeah
he doesn't come in and we can just talk
in there and the word and i can stream
it from mine or i can record it from
mine because i have the
thing for that and i was and then we can
post it on youtube
i love it um i really don't like animal
crossing and i want to end this
conversation so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to
take a little minute to give a shout out
to our newest sponsor
no more animal crossing this is about
magic spoon guys
we're not sponsored by cereal you know
how it is to be sponsored by cereal this
is healthy
is that the chocolate one yeah um i have
the blueberry one right here
and i have the fruity one there's like
there's a whole bunch of flavors
actually my favorite is the frosted one
you like the frosted one i my my
favorite wasn't the frosted one i like
the fruity ones so i like blueberry and
yeah it's just called fruity um the
chocolate one's not too bad either
um so i if you've been following me on
my instagram stories you'll see that
i've been losing weight i lost about
five pounds and i've been basically
eating a lot of
protein and i was really happy
i was really happy that we got this
sponsor when we did because this is
actually like a pretty high protein
cereal
and um it's grain free so i'm like yes
i'm trying to cut carbs
increase protein that's what i've been
doing and it's basically this kind of
reminds me of like
basically a protein shake that's
dehydrated and like turned into a cereal
or something because it's made from
milk but let's see it's got zero sugar
12 grams of protein and only three net
grams of carbs in each serving which is
wow for cereal um right now they have
four flavors
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry it
tastes amazing honestly i've been eating
the crap out of this i've been drinking
it with
regular milk too and then also i have
almond milk and hemp milk and i feel
like it tastes good with all of them
um it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb and gmo free i
mean
come on it's like per it's the perfect
cereal
anyway if you want to try it go to
magicspoon.com
mood to grab a variety pack and try it
today
be sure to use our promo code mood at
checkout to get free shipping
and also guys this is great magic spoon
is so confident in their product it's
backed with a 100 happiness guarantee so
if you don't like it they will refund
your money
because it is kind of a lot it's four
boxes it's it's a little bit expensive
but it's because it's very high quality
cereal it's not full of sugar and grain
so it's a little bit pricier than
regular cereal
but they will give you a refund if you
don't like it
so go ahead again magicspoon.com
slash mood and use the code mood for
free shipping
that is magicspoon.com mood and use the
code mood for free shipping
and thank you to magic spoon for
sponsoring this podcast
you know the blueberry one is bomb dude
it is
i'm not gonna haven't tried that one yet
i just opened it i love the blueberry
one
wow cereal for dinner it is tomorrow
yeah there we go oh they can sponsor or
eat some more stream
we want to do a speaking of going do an
animal crossing thing we want to do a
live stream
eventually like
not necessarily animal crossing
i was thinking about it too and i'm like
don't breathe
i was trying to say that we're gonna do
we're gonna start doing live streams um
we're kind of noobs at it though so
we're gonna try it on our youtube
channel
um and then we're also trying it on our
facebook page which we just launched uh
we have clips
going up there so if you ever want to
share the the show with your friends
uh the clips are a good way to do that
and like
introduce them to the show if you're
interested in like you know
sharing the link to that facebook group
well the the link to the facebook is
facebook.com
big mood girls and we'll be posting
pictures there exclusive content there
um
maybe we'll try doing live streams there
we're not sure yet we are
boomers and we're trying to figure all
this [ __ ] out yeah we're trying
were even gonna do we were trying to do
an instagram live one but i heard they
cut you off at an
hour so i think it would take us an hour
just to figure out what we're still okay
though and i mean even if it was 30
minutes we could try
yeah yeah how many people can you have
on there can you
look this up girl oh my god we are
voters
questions we don't have any answers to
would you guys like to just
do a hard commit to uh next tuesday
before we do our filming podcast and
then you guys can
like the fans can join us for a live
stream yeah this is so
fun okay yes i love that
let's do it um so when they're you guys
are seeing this
on may 26th um so next
tuesday on june 2nd we will do a live
stream
on youtube yay do
it so make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss that [ __ ] yeah exactly
and then like check out uh the instagram
pages and all that for
an exact time because this is literally
on the spot we got to plan things out
yeah well i think we just committed
right now
we might be booking a guest for next
week too so
oh we'll do it before the ball we'll
figure it out okay yeah we'll do both
[ __ ] it we'll do both we'll do two shows
yeah in one day watch the live stream
and then you have to tune in to talk to
the guests with us
how long we get to answer questions live
and stuff
yeah so fun i know live streaming is
really fun i've noticed a boom in it
since the
quarantine happened like a lot of people
are live streaming now and i
didn't really know how to do it but i've
watched joe and steve do it and um
i joined their their podcast yeah it was
so freaking fun i didn't realize four
hours passed by and i'm like yeah
i've been here my only thing is it's
only fun like if you're an audience
member while it's live
because like re-watching an old live to
me i don't like it that's why i'm like
i'm always like
a lot of you might not like it but yeah
i do like it yeah
yeah because on our patreon that's the
only place that we've been doing live
streams so it's smaller
crowd but um usually there'll be like 20
people in there that make it to the live
stream
but then like a hundred people will
watch it so oh okay
um yeah i mean it's just patreon it's
patreon only so that's
dude i watch like you know how you can
save live streams
on your instagram page i rewatched them
all the time like taiko ytt
did one and i i watched the entire thing
it was like an hour and a half
i re-watched it and it wasn't live oh
yeah
my did one too and i was like this is
tight i like it
yeah it is tight i feel like um since
everybody's in the same boat a lot of
celebrities are doing live streams and
it's just more low-key and it feels more
relatable
i haven't started to stream like actual
stream stream too
like twitch facebook and stuff
everyone's jumping on that now yeah
it's like celebrities what are they
doing they're just hanging out
yeah you can just hang out i feel like i
don't like how
uh accessible these celebrities are now
because i'm really realizing how boring
they are
they're kind of like i like i'm not
really a fan of anyone anymore now
because i'm like damn you're like not
better than me
[Music]
like they're so normal i'm like the
point of being a fan
i need someone holding them up on a
pedestal and seeing how like
normal and kind of boring they are
without a whole team of writers a whole
team of like
people putting their whole life together
they are really just
regular people and i'm like oh yeah
that's what's happening to uh go ahead
well the reason why a lot of people
follow like us for example we're
boring ass normal ass people but a lot
of people gravitate to it
okay more relatable
there being a difference though between
like celebrities and like movie stars
and stuff and i'm like
god he's boring i used to crush on him
so hard but he's so boring
this would happen with the second wave
of youtubers like
the second generation youtubers where
they were they were doing a lot of jump
cuts and there was high energy was like
hey guys
like it's very very jump cutty and then
when it when they started doing longer
form content
like podcasts or um like unedited
versions of themselves it was
way lower energy and their fans were
just like wait whoa
like you're not just like hi that's true
because
so many people like on our personal vlog
channel because casey
like he gets bored with the edit so he i
mean he has like a music video
background so he would always edit our
blogs as if like they were music videos
so they were really entertaining to
watch
um but then a lot of people started
liking the
slower pace more real life natural not
so many cuts so then we scaled back on
the cuts
and then when we scaled back on the cuts
people were like why
like why are you guys so mad like why
are you so angry and it's like
just being normal like this is this is
what happens
yeah there's so much that editing does
like to the mood and the tone
and everything yeah like i could tell
like when i first started watching
casey's vlogs versus because i was like
cutting up joe's vlogs when i first
moved out here
and i'm like i know your footage is as
boring as the one
i'm editing but i cannot make it look as
good as casey does because he just
spends so much time making it look so
much better
dude yeah it would take him an entire
week to come up with one video
and i would spend two hours on one of
joe's vlogs so you know to tell my
different people
oh yeah that's right you used to edit
those yeah i used to edit them yeah i
would put in little like
memes and stuff too but i actually
[ __ ] love my vlog channel because of
that because it's very like
low-key no expectations um it takes me
30 minutes to edit
i do add some like i love b-roll with
background music that's like my favorite
part to edit so i do have that in there
but
that part doesn't take very long and
it's just very like
i feel like my vlog channel is the best
representation of our real life
like that is exactly who we are that's
exactly what we're doing
yes some people get sick of the animal
crossing content but that's what we're
doing in life right now
that's what we're doing i'm not watching
actually like speaking about like you
know putting your life on social media
and all that and like
the vlogging stuff just like how i kind
of
created a distance between me and
opening up social media and even
interacting and like you see me be a lot
a lot less active same thing has been
going on with the vlogs actually like
like we kicked it up when quarantine
first happened because there's so many
things happening
around the house where i'm like this is
tight like i wanna i'm really [ __ ]
selfish when it comes to our vlog
channel where i'm like i am creating a
time capsule of this moment of my life
and that this is for me to watch in the
future i'm sorry
like i don't really know a lot of people
in my mind because if i do it will drive
me crazy
but i end up having these like like time
capsules of my life so then
now like when there's not a lot of
things going on in the house like i
i can't find it within me to pick up a
camera
and forces not doing anything exactly
like forcing it like to me is just not
genuine but a lot of people have true
talent in that like like mickey like
you're really good with your vlogs like
you don't
force it but you're able to like make it
like make the content entertaining still
like you're not
you're not fabricating anything but it's
still your life and it's still really
entertaining to watch like i i can't do
that and that's the reason for me
me and casey like we don't like we
struggle
with our with our vlog channel a lot
because we're like well [ __ ] what do we
talk about like yeah making things
like she can film a whole entire like
month-long saga
in just her closet incredible to me
like i know what to do i wake up
i feed my cat i stream and then i [ __ ]
off on tick tock for like the next 12
hours
you know what i think maybe it is from
um not having friends so i used to do
what i do with the camera i used to do
with my stuffed animals
and i used to be like and then we're
gonna do this okay and we're going over
here i'm gonna try
look at my new clothes that i bought so
you're basically just like a little bit
psycho and that's what makes you a good
creator
yeah yeah like so that's what it is like
you just make sure you have no friends
like all entertainers right
raise your kids with no friends
absolutely zero peers their age
give them lots of stuffed animals and a
tape recorder
there you go boom we were just talking
about this on my stream where like
everyone
that's like that's that's that's what
makes you entertaining like just people
coming like oh my god gina you're so
funny i'm like thanks it's childhood
trauma
we realized like you need to have like a
certain amount it's like
it's like a fine amount of childhood
trauma too little trauma and you're kind
of boring
you're too like vanilla too much trauma
it's like all right
stay off the heroine please calm down
you know put that
one fine bit like the right amount you
know
because of that like that exact because
i strongly believe that too like
trauma gives character like you know you
have to have you have to
live through pain not just avoid it or
um like being a [ __ ] bubble of a
happy life yeah
you need to have pain in order to have
some sort of like thick skin sense of
humor character yeah like
character exactly like it makes you who
you are right
yeah so because of all this i think
about it i'm like oh [ __ ]
like does isaac have too good of a life
a little bit he's had a little bit of
drama like with his dad and stuff so i
think that's enough that's enough
because i'm like
is he gonna grow up and like give
himself like some sort of drug addiction
because he has nothing else like no
other problem
you gotta let him hear you in case you
have sex at least like once and then
just enough enough and then he'll be
hilarious
[Music]
that's so weird that that's like such a
weird thing to be worried about like is
this my kid's life
too too good yeah also like
reading into um especially with with men
right like men who grow up really
coddled end up being a type of man when
they grow up
and so i once like knowing that like
realizing that i'm like
oh [ __ ] okay he's 12 right now as soon
as he hits 13
letting go of the reigns that's it
that's all you know because you need to
play
i cannot hold your hand like i've slowly
been like letting go
like this past year two years like two
years like he makes his own food now
like he makes he does his own laundry
good um he's in charge of his own like
room and bathroom and i'm just like
okay cool that's hard to do you can tell
when a guy like
never had to do his own laundry never
had to cook for himself like you can
tell
yeah they're the worst boyfriends the
worst
steve actually is he resents his parents
for not teaching him because he gets
super frustrated because he wants to do
a good job and he like
he wants to clean he wants to help me he
wants to do all this stuff but he just
does not
understand how and i'll explain to him
several times and he's finally starting
to get it but
in the beginning of our relationship he
would get so frustrated and he would be
so pissed he's like our kids are gonna
get taught how to clean they're gonna
get taught
i'm gonna teach them personally how to
cook or and stuff because it's not fair
because he's like
my mom was such a good mom she was great
but she never taught me any of this
stuff and so
i never had to learn and now i hate it i
hate
that i don't know how yeah you know what
you know it's another fear of mine too
is like being
too involved in his life because then
what ends up happening
some people end up reacting to the to
the
like the hovering-ness like the
helicopter
helicopter whatever they end up doing a
thing where they revert
and they're like i'm not sharing [ __ ]
with no one because like my whole life
has been like
forced to to open up and like share
everything about myself and so i'm not
like
you know like creating walls and
sometimes like i worry that i do that
with isaac a [ __ ] i'm like come on
whatever the scariest thing about him
conversation
parental fear i feel like he probably
won't want to be like in social media
like i know he says he wants to be an
actor or something but i feel like he's
actually going to start a youtube
channel
i feel like summer when he's older
though like he's going to be completely
against a
like he's just going to like you kind of
tend to do the opposite of what you got
too much of
i think yeah i don't know he wants to do
a gaming channel
no that's really cute though that's i
like that i have a question
um do you think like i mean i feel like
at this point
we've had social media for long enough
where people kind of pretty much know a
lot of shit's fake like do you think it
still really affects people
or like if it does then like why does it
still really affect people because it's
like
the in the first like five years-ish of
it like people started to realize like
oh this is really affecting me and then
like and then it wasn't until a bunch of
influencers started coming out saying
like oh this is all fake like i spent a
lot of time creating this
to look this way but it's not real so
everyone doesn't know
but like so there's so many young girls
that get like fillers
and like i feel like it's younger and
younger that are doing things that
used to be just for like older like 40
year old people like they want to get
botox they want to get fillers to look
young again
these young girls who haven't even fully
formed their faces yet
are getting fillers and and butt
implants and like
you know fake everything at such a young
age and i think
that definitely has to do with social
media and the fact that everyone looks
for sure
perfect on social media and this there's
this
definition of perfect now and there's a
new beauty standard and i feel like
everyone kind of starts to look the same
you know
oh my gosh social media is literally the
new hollywood because like
for how many decades hollywood
influenced everyone especially women
like how like badly it really like
damaged a lot of
people's psyche especially when it comes
to like self-love like they're like
morphia really like fed into the
self-hate because you're like you'll
never be as good as this
actress or this model or whatever the
[ __ ] like the fashion industry too
so all of that has now just been
condensed or i don't know if it's
condensed maybe like expanded
to social media so i feel like no matter
what there's as a
human species like we're always gonna
find something to compare ourselves to
whether it be social media or movies or
whatever isn't it weird though like that
we can't
stop doing that like because we know
with the magazines like we
know that that's completely
completely fake like we know that the
magazines are so photoshopped and now we
also know instagram is so photoshopped
but why do we keep
like you could know something in your
head logically but i think your emotions
are reacting on a subconscious level so
it it's almost like you know when you
spin things in real life when you're
like
when you fail at something you didn't
turn something in on time and then
you're like
and then my i'm just a failure like
blanket like then you start listing
things
other things you failed at in life i
think it's kind of that kind of spiral
that happens
when you're scrolling like oh my god
everyone has their [ __ ] together but me
and you start to spiral that way um but
just know it's
yeah it's like logically just be
self-aware know that it's
not real like people are just putting
their best foot forward it's like a
resume almost
online i feel like maybe it'd be most
helpful
to remind yourself like just i'm doing
me
like i'm good like yeah yeah we're good
do what makes you happy
you don't have to be like 23 years old
with the [ __ ] rules royce
traveling the world and friends with
it's not
likely by the way it's really not likely
no that that's gonna happen
yeah like that's that's that's just
that's just people that you're following
also i'm not in the 90s even though i
really really want to be
so my instagram is just like me wanting
to be the 97
you don't really wash dishes as cute as
you did in that one photo
you don't even know me jess i don't wash
dishes at all
that's [ __ ] cold
i trained steve i'm like you want to
know how to clean i'll teach you you do
dishes all the time
it's just steve doing his dishes like
yeah
he does wash dishes that cute well
anyway
that's our that's our show today guys
thank you so much for
listening thank you to our sponsors for
sponsoring um my wishlist in the 90s i'm
going to keep this space jam background
forever and pretend that's for my real
life and
um
[Laughter]
[ __ ] and it was not cool to put them on
both shoulders and you weren't
low all the way down low yes like it had
to be touching your ass and
it's not something's wrong with you yeah
like running into class like
you got an audience it's just a
projection of what your ass will be
getting in the future
jessica just answered the chat i'm like
a horror version of myself
so yes that's my mom this is my mom i
wish i had a pack of cigarettes like
gina was saying
i look like i should be like packing
some new ports
dude you definitely had a pager you were
oh yeah
girl clear pager yeah
that's a little oh my gosh oh my god you
went there
i gotta go and uh get ready for the
spring fling guys
next week um we're gonna do a live
stream next week so make sure you
subscribe
and we'll see you next time